They're importing a sculpture
You got some dirt in here
about that.
Some grass.
So this was on the ground for a long time.
You can tell.
Yeah, well, I better
I wouldn't consider this a handicraft.
I would consider this something completely
out of that remnants of sculpture.
They have the actual dirt
still falling off from there.
So you can tell that it was somewhere
for a very,
very, very long
time is dug out right from the dirt.
If it came in legally or not,
we don't know.
We just want to make sure what it is for
us so we can make that final assessment.
So let's find the other pieces
an even bigger base.
Well, what do you think they're from?
They're gonna have to call somebody
on these things,
lift this one up so we can get pictures.
The sculptures will follow
very similar patterns,
so it seems like one person made this
or the same group of people made it
look like the same kind of rock,
the same material.
I don't know what kind of rock
Neither do I.
Since it no longer has any materials
related to agriculture.
I have to refer it off to the Bonn team.
To see what further action
might be needed.
Hey, officers. How are You?
So these are a couple of the sculptures
that we found.
This is awesome.
I'm with the bond enforcement team
where a specialized unit
that responds to either
artwork, artifacts,
any type of item
that might have cultural significance.
I suspect they're monoliths
If it was new, the lines would be sharper.
We probably see tool marks,
but in this case, there aren't any.
The fact that it's still covered in soil
we're thinking they're
authentic artifacts.
This seems like a misrepresentation.
They said they're $100
each based on other items we've seen.
That's not an accurate price.
We could see the line
where it was buried in the soil.
And people
bring this into the country, but.
They know this. Crap.
You know.
Like the paperwork says it's
a certificate of origin from Cameroon.
We'd have to contact
the Cameroonian government,
see if this is legitimate
and make certain it's not falsified.
This could possibly be a black market
if it does belong to Cameroon,
the patrimony. I would highly doubt
they would allow these items
to be taken out of the country.
And now we're going to contact the subject
matter expert.
I got that funny feeling.
It will be significant,
but that will be yet to be determined.